it is perhaps Cosmic Justice that Sam
Smith and Kim Petras perform their
Satanic ritual at the Grammys and though
they they did succeed in getting some of
the attention they crave still most of
the conversation surrounding their
performance has been focused not on the
performance but on Madonna's face the
Aging former pop star introduced the two
men on Sunday night and ever since then
people have been remarking on the fact
that Madonna looked like she was having
a potentially fatal reaction to
shellfish joke like Marilyn Manson
reimagined as a muppet and I'm not being
mean here it's not my fault that Madonna
now looks like a large flightless bird
that went extinct in the pleistocene era
now Madonna herself seems to have
noticed the comments and the comparisons
and the fact that people are saying that
she looks like a ventriloquist dummy
from a Jeff Dunham act and so she sent
out this tweet the world is threatened
by my power and my stamina my
intelligence and my will to survive she
has a net worth of only
850 million dollars after all I don't
know how she manages she Wills her way
through it with sheer guts and
determination and copious amounts of
Botox